hello hi there
so our first question from Anthony MP of
Optima tea should the UK be investing in
HS - when the country's broadband
infrastructure is so bad and letting
down small and medium-sized businesses
and stopping them growing and competing
in the global economy well I think
really both we need the highest quality
transport network that we can get but
also we can't compete unless we complete
the broadband challenge and we're not
there and we're getting behind on
getting to 100% broadband on HS - I've
been clear and Labor's being clear will
support the the plan the first stage to
Crewe going through the Commons at the
moment there's a debate about getting
the best route for the second phase but
the important thing is got to be value
for money we've got to keep the cost
under control
I've been clear there's no blank cheque
for me we will go ahead on the basis
that the sums add up and its value for
money but at bitter on broadband we
can't afford to fall behind and we are
at the moment yeah you had a bit of a
wobble on on HS - a year ago is it fair
to say Shadow Chancellor you weren't
entirely convinced I said there's no
blank cheque and at that time the costs
were going up billions by billions by
billions and the government is trying to
get a grip on the costs and they've made
some progress but on the second phase I
think there's been too much focus on
only linking Manchester and the north to
London we've also got to think about
whole to Liverpool the connections east
to west aren't just as important the
Chancellor says he wants to have high
speed three after high speed - but why
should we wait to connect across the
north for 10 20 30 years we should get
on and do that as soon as we can in my
view and to be happy without a bit but
how much you committing - ages 2 -
compared to how much you're committing
committing to broadband well on
broadband we've got to get 200% we
should have been there by 2012 and we're
not going to be there by 2015 three
terms how much you committing - how much
you prepare or comfortable to spend on
ages 2
compared to spending on boob and well
what we've got to do or nature's to in
the first phase is make sure this comes
within the budgets and the government
has set but for the decade after that at
the moment it's still very unclear what
the numbers are we're talking on HS to
you about spending tens of billions in
10-15 years time on broadband it's
spending the money in the next three or
four years so I think we can get the
broadband done well before we're
spending on the second phase of Asia
thanks Ann so let's move on we will
deliver on broadband because we were the
guys who set the target the current
government is falling behind
and we've got to get back on track
because at the moment it's not good
enough okay with labor and liberals
proposals to introduce the mansion tax
there's shoes justice issues difference
between the north and the south and for
people that have owned their houses for
decades in the cells again penalize very
heavily and they're to me a completely
unmanageable scheme and I know it's a
wrong tax in my opinion what are you
going to do to level that out so it's
sure well look I didn't come into
politics to levy a mansion tax it was
never part of my my reason for being
but the problem we've got is our health
services going backwards it's
underfunded people are paying a lot more
tax already and what we know is the
highest value properties are paying a
lot less tax than ordinary properties
much less council tax compared to their
value we've said across the UK it's a UK
tax any property over two million pounds
will pay this extra attacks between two
and three million it's two hundred and
fifty pounds a month anybody who is an
ordinary basic rate taxpayer up to forty
two thousand powers will have to pay
nothing in year they can pay for them
they can pay it later so there'll be no
question of anybody being forced out of
their homes but in the end I've got to
say at a time when the deficit is huge
and the NHS is in real need we've got to
ask those people with the broader
shoulders to make a bit more of a
contribution so many of these homes not
all of them so many are own now by
international investors who've come in
from
Brod I think they should pay a fair
share of tax so we can save our NHS I
think we'd all agree with that and I
think some particularly for the
International and all these different
loot pills I see this a lot of my own
business but there again why don't you
offer tax relief for say private health
because that would release that take a
lot of pressure off the NHS wouldn't it
so you could introduce that in the end
I'm afraid anybody who gets really sick
or has a real problem comes to the NHS
because that is the highest quality
better alternative and look I can't
afford to spend tax relief money helping
people go private when we've got so sure
shortage of doctors and nurses actually
when we came to government we got rid of
the tax relief on private medical
insurance
in 1997 because we thought that was the
wrong priority what I'm saying to people
with very large properties over two
million pounds this is you know a very
very small proportion of properties you
know this will be done in a careful way
in a considered way between two and
three million pounds just 250 pounds a
month but I think it's fair to save the
NHS did you think when - when Jim Murphy
said that the mansion tax on London
would be used to fund nurses in Scotland
that's not the most helpful thing for
you is it that an argument you believe
in look it's a UK tax it will apply to
properties right across the UK over 2
million pounds and there aren't any
properties there are Feisal across the
UK but you're right to say than the
people with the largest houses and the
the greatest wealth tend to be further
south and there's a shortage of nurses
and doctors everywhere in the UK we've
said we'll have 20,000 more nurses 8,000
more GPS 5,000 more care workers this is
because the NHS is going backwards and
we need nurses and doctors in London and
in Glasgow and in Cardiff and in
Manchester and in Newcastle and it's a
fair thing to say that those with the
largest properties and the greatest
value should make a contribution so we
can save the NHS let's move on to
another question we've got a question
from I think them Facebook is that going
to come yes okay right so Oh Alan
Patterson is asking when will we get an
apology for the state labor left this
country in well I've made an apology on
the issue of bank regulation we all know
that countries around the world
including in Britain we weren't
regulating the banks and a tough enough
way but what actually happened was it
wasn't simply the ministers the
politicians the central bank governors
the bank chief executives themselves
didn't know what was going on within
their institutions and that caused huge
problems around the world now George
Osborne the Conservatives want to say it
was all Labour's fault and it was caused
by public spending when Lehman Brothers
went bankrupt in New York it wasn't
because of nurses and doctors and police
officers here in Britain it was a global
crisis we've started in America but at
his root was a lack of tough regulation
we should have been tougher so I'm sorry
about that actually my opponent George
Osborne he continually criticized me
faisal as you know because he said I was
being too tough on the banks he said I
was gonna undermine jobs by scaring
banks away why can't you be softer on
regulation and he was wrong too so sorry
about that anyone want to come back on
that this is a PSU gentleman over there
Ian Allen from the GM are you okay in
terms of where we are now compared to
where we were five years ago how do you
think we operate on the world stage at
the moment as as a player what are we
good at now what do we need to improve
on well I was in America just a few
weeks ago at the White House and at the
US Treasury and the number one thing
people were saying to me in government
and in business was is Britain really
thinking of leaving the European Union
in the next five years having a
referendum and leaving that would be a
disaster for American investment into
Britain it would undermine British
influence they couldn't believe we were
considering this so I think at the
moment we're actually playing fast and
loose with something very important are
standing in Europe and we're undermining
our influence when we ought to be
banging the table for a forum in Europe
so at the moment I don't think we're
being listened to as much as we should
be the reality is we've got some great
companies we've got some brilliant
universities we lead the world in
culture and media
our television programs sell all around
the world but we can do better and what
I would like to see us do is do better
in winning global markets but if you
walk away from your big single market on
your doorstep we walk away from you it
on Nissan on Toyota and Honda I'm gonna
stay in Britain well are they gonna
think well actually they're leaving the
single market we want to be part of
maybe we should go to Spain I think it's
a really really risky moment for our
country the next few years you're from a
car company do you agree with that well
far be it from us to tell how how our
customers had to vote or even our
employees how to vote you know where I
think the SMM T which is our trade body
gave a clear message from the car
industry that the vast majority of
businesses want to want the country to
sign Europe but you'd agree with me that
Europe can do better in these reform the
euro is not doing well enough we waste
some public spending the single market
could be more effective but the way to
be influential is to be in there making
your case and if you spend your whole
time saying to our European partners
we're thinking of leaving then they
discount us when we actually should be
influential to change the way Europe's
going most definitely gold plating gold
plating regulations just quickly a
couple of comments on the Americans are
very keen to trade with Britain because
we are so successful compared with
Germany compared with France and many
other nations in Europe said that's why
they want us to stay there because we're
stable and we're way ahead of the other
countries I hear what you're saying but
that's not what people in America say to
me they say Britain is important to
America as part of the European Union
influencing it in a good direction and
American and American companies like
Ford they want to be in Britain selling
into that European market the evidence I
hear from America is people saying that
for this country to walk away from
Europe in the next five years would be
risky and dangerous not just for Britain
but for American and French and German
and Japanese companies as well so look
I'm all for being influential and I'm
I'm all for leading the world but don't
cut off your nose to spite your face
quick quick on from here on on that same
issue just a quick question in terms of
Europe if are you saying no matter
how bad it got you'd stay in I want to
stay in but I want to win the argument
and my experience of you if I was in the
Treasury for a number of years I've been
in politics in the economy for 20 years
is it if people think you're serious and
you're committed and you're going to
make a good argument in the end you can
get your way Britain can be influential
in Europe we can change the way things
are going but if Europe decides that
you're not serious that you're playing
politics
you actually just am playing a game and
that you're kind of trying to placate
your backbenches on in the House of
Commons they give up on you we cannot
afford to let people in Europe think
Britain is given up on the jobs and the
investment which comes from being part
of Europe and I am an optimist I think
outside the single currency because that
I was one of the important people who
stopped us joining the single currency
10 years ago I don't think we should
join the euro but I am an optimist we
can be outside the euro and still win
for Britain in Europe and that's the
important thing we've got to do let's
move on another question from social
media from Facebook Alexandre Horowitz
what are your plans to help first-time
home buyers I think the the most
important thing we've got to do is to
build more homes more affordable homes
homes in places people want to live I
think one of the big mistakes the
government made a couple of years ago
was to abolish the presumption that you
would build on brownfield sites first
because that's actually where people
want to live in the cities is where the
land is and part of the reason why the
government's been pretty bad at getting
the house building numbers through is
because the developers are saying well
we don't go to brownfield let's go to
the greenfield land on the edge of the
towns and the cities that's actually
where you can only build expensive
houses and you run into big planning
problems so the answer is in the end you
can't make housing affordable for
first-time buyers unless you get more
homes being built now George Osborne
said he wants to help people to save a
deposit and that's fine by me but you
can only afford a deposit and a mortgage
if the house prices are actually related
jailed under the Labour government in
real terms
it's on your watch that I think that in
the early years of the Labour government
we didn't build enough homes I totally
agree when we came in in 1997 there were
loads of houses in our country council
houses with no bathroom inside rooms
which are leaking we said let's sort out
the existing houses a 19 billion backlog
but I don't think we built enough homes
we were turning that round 10 years ago
the financial crisis clearly has made
that harder there's no question about
that but have we at the moment got a
plan to build more homes we say 200,000
more homes a year by the end of the
decade it's a really difficult objective
I think we can deliver it but all the
quite a big push from government lady
over there
why are you concentrating on building
new homes when you're losing private
housing stock through this sharing
economy and Airbnb shouldn't you start
there what I think it's it's all of
those things I think that you need to
make sure we now have 11 million people
who live in the private rented sector
often quite difficult conditions often
on really short tendencies so we can
improve conditions and rights for people
who are private renters I do think that
it's frustrating when you see council
selling off council housing on the other
hand I don't want to say to people
you've saved they shouldn't be able to
buy their home what I get told by people
in my party we shouldn't be supporting
that I disagree because I want people to
be able to buy their their their own
home in the end though I think what all
the experts say is whatever else we do
we've got to build more homes more
affordable homes and I think that is a
big strategic challenge for our country
it's important for young people but
actually for businesses is a big deal as
well at the moment
because people are renting out their
homes for commercial use and so we're
actually in our city centres losing
existing stock
well you're right there's been a huge
rise in the number of people renting
over the last few years and that is for
some people a good choice for some
people it's a false choice because
they've got to rent while they are
saving for a mortgage if in the end you
can get house prices to a more realistic
level compared to earnings
more people will be able to buy homes
again I was able to save a deposit and
buy a house in my late 20s 20 years ago
I think it's really hard for people in
the late 20s now because in the end the
prices are just so high compared to
earnings and that if in the end look
economics is about supply and demand
unless you get the supply up build more
homes it's going to be really hard for
many people to afford it let's move on
sous-sous good questions ever lost you
ok this is a failing tax and is now
suffering growth and apprenticeships in
my own company I'm going to have to
downsize because of business rates so
what can you do to help businesses on
this front well I think you're right to
talk about the long term challenge let
me say first of all for for for small
businesses in my constituency high
levels of business rates is a huge
problem on the high street what we've
said we're going to do when we come in
we're not going to have the next cut in
the main corporation tax rate for large
companies instead we're going to use
that money to cut business rates by 1%
and then freeze them for a second year
for any business with a property which
is less than 50 thousand pounds that's
1.5 million properties in our country we
think that would give an average tax cut
of 470 pounds to a small business that
will help lots of small businesses but
it doesn't solve the underlying problem
so we also need to be thinking well what
are we going to do if you think about
Sainsbury's or next big companies
they're competing against online
retailers who may actually have their
that there their warehouses outside of
Britain they can avoid paying business
rates and they're still competing and
they let the playfield is a level so I
think it's right that we have some big
questions for the long term about
whether or not there's a better way to
to to do this at the moment the business
rates system was based upon a view of
Commerce which is quite 20th century and
win their 21st century now so could you
could you cuts business rates or could
you cut something like v80 and what
there isn't as I've said for small
companies will have a 1% cut and then
freeze for a year and that will help 1.5
small businesses immediately but for the
medium-term we need to ask some big
questions
the reality is it's expensive and I've
not got a big pot of money obviously the
deficit from George Osborne's going to
be 90 billion pounds and our NHS is in
is under real pressure so I've not got
easy solution I think we need to look
hard at this
the government's announced a review but
I think some people feel the Treasury
are using that to sort of stall the
issue I want to take this review
seriously and asked with business some
big long-term questions about the way
which business rates is working but in
the short term and then we have we have
to push on get we have to another
another issue a Kevin K and sorry just
bring you back on the deficit the 90
billion deficit is huge you said that
usual your deficit was over 150 boyo
we need to adjust the deficit yet you
want to take the austerity measures and
turn them down
why what I want to do is balance the
budget every madessa every year to get
the budget balanced in the next
parliament the national debt falling
Portugal and Ireland and look the
challenge I've got is a David Cameron
and George Osborne they said they'd get
rid of it by this year and the heavens
it's still 90 billion pounds what is
come down absolutely and and it's a good
thing it's come down and it was coming
down under labour and in in the early
part of the last decade then it went up
because of the global financial
recession and it's coming down again we
need to cut the deficit every year we
need to balance the budget in the next
parliament well you've got to do so in a
steady and careful way at the moment
George Osborne said last week he's going
to have cuts in the next three years in
public spending which are deeper than in
the last five years I think most people
think what we've seen already to our
defence forces to our police officers to
our NHS has been pretty tough even deep
for the next three years than the last
five years I'm not sure that's going to
be possible to deliver that's why I say
a more careful and balanced plan some
action on taxes at the top as we talked
about earlier we'd put the top rate of
income tax back up to 50 P for people
earning over 150,000 pounds and what
should be the whole race and I think
you'll raise a significant amount of
money it's been he put a number on
significance well the the gross cost of
the cut from 50
245 P was three billion pounds that was
how much was given to people but
obviously there's lots of a void in
economy where we spend 720 billion a
year just tinkering around the edges
when are you gonna do the big stuff I
think as you know and if you're in
business you understand three billion
pounds is a large amount of money and
what have you know one point six
trillion an economy and a government
that spends soon seven hundred and
twenty billion three billion is zero
when you're gonna do the big stuff what
I'm gonna do is get your colleague row
more strongly have some fair changes on
taxation at the top I'm going to do some
difficult things like the winter
allowance will restrict for the highest
income pensioners and also we can have a
real focus on more good skilled jobs if
we were to get the economy to grow by
just naught point two percent a year
more in the next few years
then by 2020 we'd have a fifteen billion
pound saving in the deficit that's a big
amount of money and that's actually
something which is achievable if you've
got a proper industrial plan let's say
let's move on Jules White's question on
entrepreneurship Jules okay Jules point
from the last era and so SMEs make up
99% of the British economy only eighteen
percent of those businesses are headed
by women what are you going to do to
encourage more female entrepreneurs well
I think first of all it's going to start
in the schools I've got two daughters 15
and 10 and I want them to be told in
school that they have got just as much
right and talent and ability and
opportunity to be a scientist an
engineer or a small business owner as
the boys and I think we've got more to
do as a society to get that message to
our young people in schools primary and
secondary that gender should make no
difference to your ambition and to your
opportunity then we've got to make sure
the one we're thinking about numbers of
apprenticeships for 18 year old school
leavers who might use an apprenticeship
to start a business that that those are
available for boys and girls equally and
we should try to make sure the girls are
taking up the apprenticeships and then
when you're thinking about banks how
they operate the British investment bank
which we're going to set up to lend to
small businesses
I think it's right that we're saying we
want to read to be lending to to
you need to focus on supporting women
who want to grow and expand businesses
the reality is if you actually look at
the numbers in Britain and in America
then very many of the most dynamic most
successful businesses in our country
have been set up and run by women in my
constituency a fabulous business which
makes wigs just down the road from my
office brilliant business expanding very
fast but I think there's more we can do
to break some of the cultural views in
banks and in schools which say well you
know maybe that's not something for
women it's ridiculous the issues a
little bit deeper isn't it and the young
lady over there mentioned earlier that
Xero contract hours are predominantly
aimed at women and and those that are
older so so why is that what's wrong
with the society what are you going to
do with that issue why not encourage
those people that are being really
violated and and you know just taken
advantage of personally I think it's
gone too too far what's happened with 0s
contracts a huge rise 400,000 more in
the last year alone and we want to have
a labor market which creates jobs and
works in a flexible way but if that
means that all the risk is actually
being borne by lower paid vulnerable
people who are not finding out day to
day where they're gonna earn where
they'll have money to pay the bills
that's not not fair and we've said we're
not going to outlaw all zero-hours
contracts because there are for some
people especially higher skill certain
kind of professional people where it can
make real sense but fought for for very
many people it's exploitative and we're
going to change the rules so for example
say for example if you have been on a
zero as contract but we're but working
effectively regular hours for six months
you should have the right to move to a
proper regular contract rather than
being stuck on a zero hours contract a
year that should happen automatically
and we're also saying to people and zero
hours contracts if you're told by an
employer that you have to be on zero
hours but you can't work for anybody
else well that should be against the law
because people shouldn't be stuck
without the ability to work but told by
the employer if you don't stick with me
then I'll take away your contract
there's things we can do to make this
better and fairer and I actually the
business community now understands on
zeros contracts it's gone too far
it's an Lea just a quick question your
question on farming Tonya we've just got
two minutes self-sufficiency our
country's ability to feed itself with
whom produce food is on a downward
spiral if I take it you'd be in favor
averting that what would your government
do to help British farming I'm am all
for backing British farming but the
reality is we are part of a open global
economy and it's good that we have
international trade and international
trade means that there's some kind of
products if you go to the supermarket
you can buy a much wider a range of
produce and also offered at cheaper
prices and because of international
trade and for people who are struggling
to make ends meet with living standards
under pressure that's a good thing so
I'm for international trade I don't like
the Common Agricultural Policy because I
think it costs consumers quite a lot
what we've got to do is help our farmers
in order to keep upgrading the their
produce their equipment their their
productivity that's the only way for
them to stay ahead of the of the
competition so when you talk about
Industrial Policy that should be
agriculture as well as for
pharmaceuticals well I think we just
have to wrap so are you for more farming
subsidies or for less personally I'm
firming for less farming substantive
that I think the Common Agricultural
Policy is hugely wasteful that's the
kind of reform in Europe I'd like to see
you can take the Treasury man our
vegetables right